bonjour thierry claveau bonjour monsieur
tout cet intervenant en droit électoral
notamment centre national de la fonction
publique et territoriale également sifem
le 6 films c'est le centre d'information
et de formation des élus locaux de la
martinique merci d'être avec nous car
nous sommes à 12 jours aujourd'hui de ce
premier tour de la présidentielle
française nous allons rappeler les
règles pour tout le monde tirait claveau
première chose on vote ce samedi si
c'est un acquis mais il ya quand même
une nouveauté cette année les bureaux
fermeront à 19h oui en fait c'est pas
une nouveauté pour cette année seulement
c'est une nouveauté pour toutes les
années à venir c'est à dire que
traditionnellement les bureaux de vote
fermaient à 18 heures est dorénavant il
fait au moins dix-neuf quelle que soit
l'élection
maintenant il ya une particularité pour
certaines communes de la martinique qui
l'ont qu'ils ont souhaité le préfet par
un arrêté à prolonger le l'ouverture des
bureaux pour certaines communes jusqu'à
20 heures
pourquoi ben parce que il ya certaines
confessions religieuses kinky qui se
consacrent à leur religion le samedi et
jusqu'au coucher du soleil
il se consacre à 7 à cette activité et
donc par conséquent c'est seulement
quand le le soleil couché qui pourront
faire leur devoir électoral donc c'est à
la demande des communes
c'est à la demande de certaines communes
alors on a voté et le soir même on a les
résultats de chaque bureau de chaque
commune et là il y a une obligation de
proclamer les résultats dans les bureaux
dans le bureau centralisateur parce que
tout ce qui se passe dans un bureau de
vote et public par conséquent opposable
à tout cas tout électeur et donc il faut
une proclamation des résultats
1 néanmoins c'est pas pour autant qu'on
ait autorisé aller à les publier
ouais vous journalistes vous savez très
bien à quoi vous vous donnez si vous
publiez les résultats alors que le
territoire national n'a pas encore ne
s'est pas encore prononcée donc il faut
bien différencier la proclamation des
résultats dans le bureau et la diffusion
par exemple si je suis présent dans le
bureau centralisateur du saint-esprit
commune où je suis né est-ce que je peux
appeler ma mère mon père mes frères et
mes soeurs pour leur dire que tel
candidate arrive en tête
oui c'est une conversation purement
privée et je ne vois pas comme qu'elle
n'est pas que ça peut avoir sur ce comme
ça peut influencer l'électeur au niveau
national est le seul fait de discuter
avec votre mère ne va pas influencé
toute la france il faut vraiment que ça
soit très très gentil très limité dans
le nombre de contacts qu'on a
oui c'est une élection nationale il
s'agit pas d'un enjeu local et que par
conséquent le fait de discuter avec ses
parents ou son cousin aussi boîte ça ne
remet pas en cause de sa frustration
levé sur des réseaux sociaux c'est autre
chose
oui on sait à quoi on s'expose deuxième
chapitre je vote et je vote car je suis
inscrit on peut s'inscrire jusqu'à trans
est trop tard pour ce premier tour de la
présidentielle c'est route à
on peut enlever s'inscrire jusqu'au 31
décembre 2016
par contre il ya certains cas
exceptionnels comme les gens qui sont
mutés éventuellement dans certaines
boîtes c'était fonctionner c'était
militaires qui sont entrés chez eux
c'est l'article 30 du code électoral et
donc ces gens là faculté de demander
leur inscription auprès de la commission
de révision des listes électorales
jusqu'au dixième jour précédant le scout
et voilà on peut également contesté ces
listes électorales lorsqu'on arrive par
exemple qu'on voit qu'on y parle il ya
encore une autre possibilité vous voyez
que le législateur a prévu un certain
nombre de dispositions pour favoriser le
vote parce que le but du jeu c'est ça
c'est de faire voter le maximum de
personnes
c'est à dire que jusqu'au jour du
scrutin il peut résulter d'une erreur
plus mon matériel que les lakers se ne
se retrouvent pas on ne retrouve pas les
lecteurs sur la liste d'émargement et
que par conséquent les lecteurs pourra
faire jouer l'article l 34 c'est à dire
liés au matériel et ça s'est avancé par
le juge d'instance donc il faut voilà
tout à fait c'est une démarche d'aller
au personnel de l'électeur qui doit lui
même se vendent au tribunal ce qui est
un petit peu contraignant parce qu'il y
en a qui se découragent
ils se disent ah mais moi j'ai pas le
temps sans café rex était là il se
dégage mais c'est une faculté que
qu'offre le code électoral et la
procuration maintenant jusqu'à quand je
peux obtenir cette boucle à la
circulation elle et jusqu'au jour du
scrutin bon bien sûr c'est le problème
qui se pose avec les populations c'est
toujours le problème de l'acheminement
de la population parce qu'il faut quand
même qu'elle soit adressée au maire 1 et
par conséquent aujourd'hui l'utilisateur
a compris que le politique qui
consistait à envoyer les populations par
les trois commandés ne se fait plus
selon les gendarmes les officiers
policière qui en mènent eux-mêmes les
procurations en exergue est tout à fait
et aussi la faculté de les transmettre
par fax bien sûr sous réserve de
vérifier auprès de l'autorité qui a
établi la population pour éviter toute
toute fraude et possibilité de l'envoyer
par face à la possibilité d'envoyer par
mail sous certaines conditions bien sûr
et
donc tout ça est admis maintenant et la
curation c'est jusqu'à quand mais je les
dis jusqu'au jour du scrutin vous pouvez
bon dans la mesure du possible du moment
que les officiers de police du ciel sont
enfin les gendarmeries sont ouverts que
jusqu'au jour du scrutin
troisième chapitre retirer claveau très
important l'organisation dans les
bureaux et ça peut devenir le parcours
du combattant
les règles en la matière tout est
codifié y compris par exemple
l'enveloppent qui doit être posé sur la
table est pas remise par le maire mais
peut-être avant d'arriver à ce chapitre
une fois que je rentre dans le bureau il
doit y avoir tout premier contrôle oui
alors bien sûr un contrôle préalable je
tiens à préciser quand même que il faut
distinguer le rôle du maire de celui du
président de bureau de vote le maire en
charge l'organisation matérielle des
élections
1 c'est lui qui met en place tout et des
loques le scrutin est ouvert enfin même
avant le président du bureau de vote
prend le relais pour ce qui concerne le
déroulement des opérationnels ce
président c'est le maire c'est le maire
par contre son suppléant est désigné par
lui même c'est pas le maire qui désigne
le suppléant du président de l'autre
alors pour revenir à votre question
effectivement l'électeur doit dans son
comportement dans le bureau de vote
il doit d'abord faire l'objet d'un
contrôle préalable à l'entrée
ce contrôle préalable permet de vérifier
son doigt à voter dans le bureau et se
et ce pour éviter tout cafouillage c'est
à dire que c'est pas lorsqu'ils arrivent
devant le président qu'on constate que
finalement il n'est pas inscrit dans ce
bureau l'arrêt voyez-vous et donc ça
évite des incidences invite les ddd des
filets après contrôle il
c'est la carte d'identité c'est là qu'en
donnant sa carte d'électeur ou avec sa
carte d'identité façon la carte de
visite obligatoire dans toutes les
communes jusqu'à enfin à partir juste à
partir de 1000 habitants
la carte d'identité obligatoire voilà
donc une fois ce premier contrôle fait
qu'est ce qui se passe alors s'unir via
cette fameuse enveloppe tout à fait à
l'os et quand l'électeur est admis à
voter on constate qu'il a dit là il a le
droit de voter dans ce bureau
par conséquent il se dirige vers la
table de décharge
cette table de décharge
qui doit être isolé d'ailleurs qui n'a
personne à se trouver derrière pour
influencer les lecteurs audio points
bulletin des repas pour bulletins dans
la sas est une chose importante est
souhaitable des changes doivent être
disposées donc les bulletins des
candidats dans l'ordre du conseil
constitutionnel oui et les enveloppes de
scouts et ce sont ces fameuses petites
enveloppes là qui font une obsession
chez certains élus mais pour qui son
aide mais vous n'êtes pas ce qu'il ya
d'intéressant que vous le signale gay
parce que moi j'ai déjà assisté à des
mères mi temps oui parce que ils ont
offert deux présidées par le président
lemaire qui remet l'enveloppé gelé déjà
vu mais à un moment donné je vais faire
le mais attention le maire il aimait
recettes mais à ce moment là il est
président du bureau de vote et donc par
conséquent non non c'est pas c'est une
obsession parce que on ne veut pas que
alors qu'en fin de compte le le le fond
du problème c'est quoi c'est que les
lecteurs
il prend même si pour deux enveloppes
admettons en étant un bon du moment
qu'il introduit une seule enveloppe dans
l'urne
c'est ce qui est important maintenant si
entre-temps il n'y a pas suffisamment
développe ont fait complété par la
mairie ses parades mais l'électeur prend
lui-même son enveloppe et cela résulte
d'une d'une pratique qui se faisait sur
tous les territoires nationale où
certains maires de petites communes de
250 300 habitants 500 habitants qui
connaissaient nos électeurs connaissait
d'ailleurs leurs adversaires et bien
avait la fâcheuse manie de mettre du
gras sous l'eau mais et puis d'imbiber
d' enveloppe dans ce qui fait que
l'enfant étant identifiées donc le vote
est nul et donc c'est pas pour huis clos
lisa terrain situé za bon on oublie deux
ou trois petites choses par exemple
thierry claveau que le dépouillement est
publique
on doit avoir accès au procès-verbal
tout citoyen doit avoir accès à cela il
ya des mairies des des bureaux où on
ferme les portes au moment du
dépouillement est ce assez
c'est cet artisan est interdite d un
mariage sauf sauf s'il procureur a
autorisé un huis clos mais un même
mariage et public une élection encore
plus c'est une affaire publique
le dépouillement doit se passer sous le
contrôle les électeurs j'ai vu des
mairies se fermer pour en déprimant mais
qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je vous
dise je faisais je faisais en fait
j'aime à le répéter
dans en matière électorale s'est pas vu
pas pris si personne ne conteste
je ne vois pas comment quelqu'un va
s'autosaisir notoriété va s'autosaisir
problème pourquoi ça ferait ça perdure
c'est pratique l'association sentiers du
nord mais on ne rappelle pas ça c'est ça
je me permets de le dire sans vouloir
remettre en cause c'est vrai qu'il
sollicite pas suffisamment le sifel le
siphem d'ailleurs qui présidé par le
maire du coeur béquille très dynamique
dans son action et et ceci fait n'est
pas suffisamment sollicités par les élus
alors que nous sommes à leur disposition
il nous resterait très peu de seconde en
une question très pratique lorsque les
messages ont beaucoup circulé ces
derniers temps sur les réseaux sociaux
la guyane de nombreux messages ont
circulé disant que s'il arrive la grève
se poursuivait que le vote ne pourrait
pas se faire normalement et que ce vote
dans l'ensemble de la présidentielle
pourrait être est validé le vrai du faux
dans tout ça tient la route et moi je ne
peux pas je ne suis pas
docteur en droit constitutionnel mais je
vais vous dire que je ne pense pas 1
simplement je ne pense pas que ça va
influencer pas du tout c'est bien c'est
dit c'est fait comme ça merci thierry à
vos mails sans appel que nous sommes à
12 jours du premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle et convoquera le samedi
en martinique avant la france le
lendemain merci bonne journée